Bitcoin people on Twitter oh my god
I've never I have I've gone at the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia nobody goes
harder than people who believe in
Bitcoin on Twitter
hey I'm hustle manage I'm here to answer
the internet uh debate the internet what
president throughout history would be
the best in an Air Force One movie
situation I have to be a president that
would uh be good with a gun
combat let's let's look at like let's go
through like it would probably be who
could act like it probably Reagan yeah
you know who's actually good at
hand-to-hand combat I feel like bro no I
actually feel like Nixon would have
[ __ ] people up
yeah yeah I feel like probably Nixon
Nixon yeah he had a lot of rage I got
guitar you know we all heard the tapes
anybody by the way any president
pre-tv era
yeah it's not like Taft isn't [ __ ]
anyone up like not happening all right
do you think there are more porn stars
or murderers in the world I go murders
probably you gotta be well you got I
don't know it depends on the definition
of porn star also and also yeah yeah
murder manslaughter true car accident
yeah
soldiers yeah well it's killing people
it's probably gonna be yeah yeah Killers
it's probably Killers it's probably
murderers and then only fans probably
chip [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah by the way
shout out to the CEO of only fans she
reached out and she liked the special I
don't know if she's asking me to join
only fans of it I make a boatload this
is all my only my only fans would just
be like the times that my daughter
paints my toenails yeah I don't know if
you're into this yeah
this is real bro this whole left foot by
the way this whole left foot is just all
it's just green nail polish debate the
internet if you could go to any sporting
event ever which would it be I'd go game
seven uh Cavs Warriors when the Cavs
came back from that 3-1 and beat the
Warriors the LeBron the LeBron block
yeah awesome that's such a Sacramento
answer though because like yeah anyway
no yeah yeah any anytime I can I can
[ __ ] on another city from Cali if I can
watch the bay or the or the Lakers lose
come on would you rather date a girl who
laughs at everything or laughs at
nothing I'm married to a girl who laughs
at nothing so loud
said nothing would you rather be 15 or
50 for the rest of your life I'll be
honest man
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go with 50. I
feel like I already just I was born as
like a a 58 year old man so
dude I'm embracing I'm gonna embrace my
Phil Jackson ears my Phil Jackson years
come on bro 15 my sophomore year I
thought Ja Rule was the greatest rapper
of all time hey
there was there was like a little Benny
vidibiche era that like that was the era
Mary [ __ ] kill gushers Fruit by the Foot
shark bites
wow shout out to shark bites can we have
also like uh you know they recently
brought these back dunkaroos you know
how they're like they're bringing back
like they're bringing back Rugrats
They're bringing back I didn't know bro
I don't know that they did no no for you
no no no no I think like dunkaroos like
went insolvent yeah and like somebody
and then they brought him back so so by
the way like we're stocking up right now
because our house we go hard in the
paint for Halloween like yeah I'm like
I'm not playing games like you're you're
yeah you're coming yeah so we do full
size we do the whole thing because I I
heard that if you growing up I heard if
you went to Michael Jordan's house they
would do full size remember the 20 the
23 gate whatever so I was like all right
I'm gonna go hard yeah so I'm like we do
we I saw him in Target I was like oh
dunkaroos are back so we bought
dunkaroos but Mary [ __ ] killed gushers
Fruit by the Foot shark bites yo shark
bites are pretty incredible the best I'm
putting a ring on shark bites yeah I'm
putting I'm putting a ring on that
definitely
um [ __ ] some gushers kill Fruit by
the Foot I'd be I'll be honest with you
kind of overrated it doesn't hold it
doesn't it does actually really doesn't
hold it it's like it's like it's like
with cereal like when I was a kid Froot
Loops was the [ __ ] if you have Fruit
Loops now you're like whoa like yeah but
Cinnamon Toast Crunch is like that's
forever that's all time go who's the
worst group of fans people who believe
in Bitcoin
bro Bitcoin people on Twitter oh my God
bro I've never I have I've gone at the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia nobody goes
harder than people who believe in
Bitcoin on Twitter all right Colvin can
I change this one yeah but I still I
think we've come back what is James wash
your hands okay what is your stance on
washing your hands after taking a piss
I've seen people on this position I do
wash my hands
yeah
bro come on man all right and then and
then and then by the way and by the way
I'll do this I do this with the I've
like my cousin taught me that one like
earlier that way yeah by the way there's
a divide right now it's not even that's
not even the real card there's a new
debate that we gotta have and this is
this is [ __ ] dividing the country our
country is more divided than ever
there's people with Clean Air Force Ones
and there's people with dusty ass
greasy I ran through the Mojave Desert
Air Force Ones these are just grimy ass
moldy I'm not in there busted Air Force
yeah
and and those two camps do not see eye
to eye I do Canvas I'll let you know
which side of the like you know what I
mean this is this is the camp I'm on and
I know people will be like oh you old
ass [ __ ] no no no no no I just I
just respect history I respect
institutions in this country I would
never disrespect
one of our branches of government the
Air Force was where black Air Force was
no that's I mean no yeah
I haven't killed anyone and
I haven't been to a federal penitentiary
I wear I wear white Air Force Ones yeah
yeah if there was stats available for
every aspect of your life what is one
stat
that you would want to see oh wow bro
okay people don't know this I'm amazing
at finessing hotels and getting late
checkouts dude I can finesse a 6 p.m
checkout anybody who travels you your
ass gotta be out by 12 p.m I can finesse
a 6 p.m checkout and I'm very proud
I've probably racked up I'm in double
digits sometimes I'll put on a British
accent I'll use schedule
according to my schedule oh your
schedule I'm sorry
and I think that'd be a good one it
doesn't have to be a good one you could
just like kind of have like scheduled
like oh yeah okay
yeah oh let me let me check my schedule
like uh no no no sir it's okay
yeah and they're like sir this is a
Hampton Inn but 6 p.m is so
disrespectful because it's like nobody
can check in today would you kill Baby
Hitler if it had to be in a very
gruesome way yeah of course
[Laughter]
it has to be in a gruesome way yeah all
right okay yeah
yeah cool all right
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out